bonsoir osef venelles merci d'être avec
nous une réforme des retraites en
septembre
clairement ça pourrait relancer les
gilets jaunes dans la rue et pas que
d'ailleurs clairement pour qu'il réforme
il faut qu'ils aient une acceptabilité
de cette réforme et il me semble que
quoi qu'on pense sur le fond
l'acceptabilité n'y est pas pour
différentes raisons la première si on
l'a vu le pouvoir politique est
marginalisé 70 % de personnes qui ne
vont pas voter le la majorité entre
guillemets présidentiel faisant un
chiffre epsilon ça ne porte pas une
majorité à pouvoir prendre des décisions
l'acceptabilité c'est aussi la confiance
qu'on peut avoir dans le politique
et quand j'entends des mini 10 ne vous
inquiétez eu de réforme elle se fera
dans un large au dessus et bien
j'entends aussi les mêmes qui nous avait
dit qu'une réforme qui touchait la ville
et biotechnologies serait dans un large
consensus
ils ne l'ont pas fait et donc le temps
me semble pas venu pour réformer sur les
retraites surtout y at il urgence
y at il urgence mais feuillane nécessité
tout de même parce que tout le monde
semble s'accorder à dire qu'il ya une
forme de nécessité dans cette réforme ce
n'est pas votre avis mais quelle d'abord
la réforme elle et elle est en cours sur
les retraites en permanence je
rappellerai simplement que pour les
salariés du privé
on était il n'ya pas si longtemps à 36
ans de cotisations on est passé à 42 ans
et maintenant ses 43 ans
que l'on prenait pour les salariés du
privé la dernière année puis les 10
meilleures années
puis les 25 meilleures années qu'on
calcule et avec une indexation sur
l'inflation et maintenant c'est sur les
salaires c'est à dire que la réforme des
retraites
elle est faite en permanence qu'on nous
dise pas que ce n'est pas fait qu'on
nous dise pas que les salariés du privé
n'ont pas fait des efforts considérables
ces dernières années passées de 36 cents
à 43 ans ce n'est pas rien passé de la
dernière année pour calculer la retraite
aux 25 meilleures années
ce n'est pas rien alors maintenant on va
me dire oui mais un problème de budget
alors le coût des retraites c'était en
tout cas en 2018 c'est le dernier
chiffre qu'on est exact 310 milliards
d'euros oui mais c'est pas un coup parce
que ses 310 milliards d'euros ils
repartent dans la consommation
ils permettent aux gens de payer des
loyers d'acheter de logement et donc il
faudrait considérer les choses dans leur
réalité
les retraites c'est aussi ce qui permet
au pays de fonctionner et j en crise du
coup vide qu'on avait la capacité tout
d'un coup de nous sortir des mots et
comment se fait-il que pour les saluer
pour leur assurer une retraite décente
la machine à euro ne pourrait pas
fonctionner mes pensées pour le coc vide
elle peut fonctionner j'aimerais
comprendre aujourd'hui clairement quel
est le choix des manuels macron donnera
rien faire au risque d'être taxé de roi
fainéant qui ne tient pas ses promesses
ou de trop faire est de mettre tout le
monde dans la rue il est piégé
clairement sur ce dossier emmanuel
macron il s'est sans doute piéger tout
seul mais le choix c'est quoi le choix
c'est de poser les choses pour que
chaque personne qui aura travaillé toute
sa vie puisse vivre dignement et ce qui
sort de la réunion d'aujourd'hui c'est
nous allons réfléchir ensemble pour
l'acf tu essaies oui
regarde regardons les métiers
particulièrement pénible est-ce qu'il
faut les bouger comment faut-il les
bouger comment on finance est le
retraite mais encore là des réserves
considérables
il n'y a pas une urgence absolue et si
on se projette à une horizon de 20 25
ans on s'aperçoit que la masse du baby
boom qui était déjà en retraite battitta
petit elle va disparaître parce que
comme chaque être humain nous sommes
mortels est donc cette grande masse va
disparaître et donc le coût des
retraites va mécaniquement baisser aussi
il faut mettre ça sur la table
tranquillement et non pas se précipiter
sur un débat qui est plus politicien que
réelle pourtant joseph tomblaine ainsi
on revient c'est dur parce qu'avec le
vide entre temps quelques mois en
arrière un peu plus d'un an même le
gouvernement nous dise et mais nous on a
parfaitement concerter les partenaires
sociaux d'ailleurs la loi voilà était
quasiment passé un donc qu'est-ce que
vous répondez au gouvernement abbas et
c'est très simple discuter avec les
partenaires sociaux
recueillir leur avis ça veut pas dire la
part du gouvernement et c'est normal le
gouvernement gouverne être d'accord avec
les partenaires sociaux
on voit bien qu'elle est différenciée
danse entre organisations syndicales y
ait des différences avec les
organisations patronales le gouvernement
son rôle c'est de gouverner notre rôle
ou en tout cas syndicalistes de la cftc
c'est de représenter et défendre les
salariés
en prenant en compte le bien commun
c'est-à-dire l'activité de l'ensemble du
pays
il nous semble que lens qui est proposée
pour les retraites et ce qui était
proposé
il y avait des choses avec lesquelles on
était d'accord et d'autres avec lesquels
on n'était pas d'accord
par exemple faire baisser les retraites
pour les cadres qui cotisent beaucoup et
qui sont largement bénéficiaires ne nous
semble pas juste
merci joseph a tourné à linge rappelle
que vous êtes secrétaire confédéral de
la scène
et merci d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rcj